what the designers a Bitcoin created was
a way to make a ledger that's secure and
that everyone can trust but that no one
owns or controls and this allows people
to have money that can be free of the
influence of governments which is both
bad if you're a government and great if
you don't like what governments do with
their monetary policies it lets the
policy be set by consensus and software
so Bitcoin basically has found a way to
always know what the majority thinks and
by always knowing what the majority
thinks you get something you you hope
you can trust well the only thing people
use Bitcoin for today is effectively to
write checks that transfer title in some
bitcoins to another person or another
secret number to count it actually
becomes possible to do things like a
write a contract and say I transfer one
Bitcoin to you if the following is true
and so now the contracts are enforced
without courts without any other third
party so the ability for people to just
play with that and innovate with that
that's really exciting and that's why
you want to pay attention to a bit point
you